- It's time for my first guest.
He's an Emmy winner for
his role on Will and Grace.
He's also the insanely
successful producer of shows like
Grimm, Hot in Cleveland
and Hollywood Game Night.
Right now he's hosting a
podcast alongside his friends,
Jason Bateman, and Will
Arnett called Smartless.
Sean Hayes, get in here.
- Oh my God, wait, are we starting?
This is it?
- (laughs loudly) I really
want you to intro the show
just like that.
Oh my gosh, wait.
- Wait, because I didn't,
I didn't speak to anybody,
but you just kind of
appeared like Jesus Christ--
- I just, and that's how life is,
I just appear and just bless your life.
- It's incredible.
- So wait, is it true that,
so you and Scott y'all added
to your family during lockdown?
- Yes, we did.
Do you wanna see this person?
- Yes, because I have a Goldendoodle.
- Oh, you do?
- Yes, Henry come here.
- Wait, I wanna see.
- He was just in here a minute ago.
- Is he awake?
(whistles)
- Where you at love?
Come here, come here,
come here, oh my God.
- Oh my gosh he's huge.
- He was supposed to be a miniature...
Hi, he was supposed to be
a miniature, but he's not.
He's like 40 pounds (chuckles)
His name is Henry.
(gasps) Stop it!
Oh my God.
- I woke him up and he's sleeping.
- Does he have puppy breath?
- Yes.
(Kelly gasps)
If puppy breath means horrible,
horrible breath like mine,
then yes.
- Oh my God, in the morning, yeah.
No, it's so funny.
So how big is your Goldendoodle gonna get?
Is that a miniature or
normal, like a regular?
- It's normal, it's normal.
His parents are, you know,
like 50 to 60 pounds.
- Well, this one was
supposed to be 15 to 18,
lies and deception.
You're about 40.
But he is the sweet...
Goldendoodles or so...
So the reason why I went
for it, is 'cause we had...
Oh my God, I used to hold him like a baby.
- He's so cute.
- Yeah, they're the best, right?
Especially in quarantine.
'Cause it can be super depressing.
- And I only have like, it's not that bad,
I only have like five nannies for him.
Can you, can you come and
see, watch, I just do this.
Can you just, thank you so much.
- One, hello?
One feeds, one walks, one naps with,
I love your five nannies.
- Wait, and then Scotty,
will you put a treat in this?
Okay, thanks.
- Wait, did you tell me his name?
I didn't, I missed it.
- Oh his name is Ricky.
- Ricky, I love it.
Like Ricky, Bobby, or what
did we name Ricky after?
- Scotty named him Ricky.
I don't know why, why Scotty?
- [Scotty] Just because--
- Just 'cause, it's the first
name that came to his head.
- [Kelly] I love it.
So his new podcast is called
Smartless, which is awesome.
So tell me about the podcast.
Why is it called Smartless?
- Yeah so Smartless, Jason actually...
Smartless has three hosts.
It's me, Jason Bateman, and Will Arnett.
And no, we don't talk
about Ozark the whole time.
- (laughs loudly) I love--
- It comes up a lot
though, It comes up a lot.
But we've been friends for
20 something, 20-ish years
and known each other.
Yeah, and we just played poker decades ago
every Tuesday night.
And so we just thought, why don't we...
We've always wanted to work together
and we've always all three
work together, like separately,
but never together.
And so like let's get
into the podcast thing
and have an excuse to hang out every week
and talk about stuff we don't know about
because we're all idiots.
And talk about people
who know more than us
and that's why it's called Smartless
because we wish we were smarter.
And so it's famous people,
it's not famous people.
It's people from all
different walks of life,
like Neil deGrasse Tyson comes on
and talks about astrophysicist.
I mean talks about--
- I love him.
- Yeah, he's the best.
- I mean I love him
and then he can like
scare the crap out of you.
- Yeah, like the worlds
gonna end tomorrow--
- Like I didn't realize the
definition of black hole
would literally send me into
nightmares for like a month.
- Yeah, and that the earth
is gonna get eaten up
by black hole one day, so thanks.
- It's like, oh, solid.
- Merry Christmas!
- Yeah, that's awesome, I love that.
I love to hear that you're just...
That must be a cool
outlet especially now too.
- We started, we were gonna do...
We started talking about it
and organizing it in January.
So we were gonna do it anyway,
and then this happened.
So it just kind of worked out perfectly.
- Yeah, that's awesome.
Okay, so one thing I
love about your podcast,
y'all's podcast is that,
is it true that y'all,
you bring someone and they
have no idea who's coming
and then they bring someone
and then you have no idea
who you're gonna be interviewing?
- Right, so every episode,
one of us acts as the
host and brings on a guest
that the other two don't know about.
And so it's a surprise
reveal to the other two
and the audience.
Although marketing, we'll let
the audience know who's on,
but so it's cool in the
moment the other two
become kind of the
audience and ask questions
off the top of their head
where the other one drives the interview.
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
Has it ever happened to where
one of them has been like,
yay (laughs loudly) you know?
- You know what, for me, I
know nothing about sports.
So I'm like, I don't really know--
- Me either.
- And then I learn about the
person and I'm fascinated.
So I love when I'm surprised
when the other two brings,
someone I don't know about.
- I wanna be a surprise, can
I be your surprise one day?
Or do you not (indistinct)
Does it matter?
- Yes, yes, yes.
I would love that, that'd be
so fun, they would flip out.
- Well, I kind of, you said
that y'all played poker.
I kind of have trouble,
like thinking that you have
a really good poker face.
'Cause I've played games with you.
(laughing)
like I don't have a
good poker face either.
I'm literally like, I get
a good hand and I'm like.
- Yeah, I start laughing.
I'll just start laughing.
I know I'm the worst if
somebody's like, yeah.
It's the worst.
- I love poker though that's fun.
Y'all should do that again.
That's fun.
- Yeah, or virtually, yeah.
- All right, all right.
So, okay, well let me try and experiment.
Try, I want you to try
and keep a straight face.
'Cause I know that you're gonna laugh.
While I give you something to
kind of spark your interest.
So I'm gonna try out your
bluff face, are you ready?
- Okay, okay.
- [Kelly] You have to be serious.
- I'm already losing it.
I already lost, okay go.
- Okay, cool, banana bread.
You can't hold your face (laughs)
Okay, new puppy!
(Sean laughs)
Do you not---
Okay, cool.
Now just don't smile.
- Okay (laughs)
That's really funny.
- We're like the same person
in male and female form.
I couldn't do it either.
Okay, so I have to know about this.
I heard, my producers are telling me,
did you steal a sandwich
from someone at some point
and they you ended up
like literally in jail?
- Yeah, I sure did--
- I gotta know this story
'cause that's an awesome story.
- Yeah, I think I was 18 years old,
well, I was 18 years old.
I was in my freshman year in
college and I had no money
and just like zero money.
I don't know how I even bought a book--
- That was me at age 18 as well, yes.
- Right, and so we we
all went out one night
and we were walking back from a party
and there was a kind
of like a, not 7-Eleven
but a 7-Eleven type store.
And so he walked in and
I was like, oh my God,
I'm starving haven't eaten all day.
And I stole a Turkey sandwich.
And so I walked outside with
my friends and I'm like,
eew it has tomatoes on it.
So we started throwing
tomatoes in the street
because we were dorks and
losers and then I'm eating it
and we're all laughing and comes up a cop,
stands right in front of me.
And I just see like his badge
and I look up to his face.
He's like, you need to come with me.
And I'm like, are you joking me?
He's like, no.
So I get into the cop
car, I had to go to jail.
This kid bailed me out, his name is Liam.
He was the nicest guy...
I didn't know him.
And he gave me the a hundred bucks--
- You didn't know him
and he bailed you out?
- Yeah because it was part of like,
you know, it was freshman year in college.
Everybody's kind of meeting everybody.
So I didn't know him that well,
like I, but he was so nice.
And so I borrowed the a 100$
from my brother the next day.
And I paid him back and then cut to,
I don't know how many years
later, I'm in Los Angeles
and I met at cafe and the guy comes up,
my waiter and he goes, do you remember me?
I was like, no, he goes, I'm
Liam, I bailed you out of jail.
- No way!
- I was like, wait, what?
That's so crazy.
'Cause I hadn't seen
him after he did that.
He liked transferred schools
or something or left.
And, isn't that crazy?
- That is crazy,
well, what's crazier is I
have a surprise for you,
Liam, come on in the Zoom room.
No, I'm just kidding.
(laughing loudly)
- Could you imagine, could you imagine?
- I'm just kidding I just
wanted to see your bluff face
and by the way it looks
like this, oh (bleep)
(laughing)
All right, I'm just kidding.
I was checking your poker
face, we don't have anything.
- Yeah no, I have none, I have none.
But if you probably had him on,
that would be the best surprise ever.
I always wonder what happened to him.
- I know I do love running into people.
I had so many odd jobs
before this or all these jobs
and I do...
It's funny when you
randomly run into people
and it's out of context
and then you're like,
it's almost like certain smells bring back
such nostalgic memories or certain things.
It's the same thing.
You're like, oh my God.,
it was a lifetime ago.
- Well in some sense smell
is the number one sense
associated with memory.
- Yes, no, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that.
One thing we like to do
in these remote shows
is get a feel for our guests homes.
Now we've already seen a
little bit of his media room,
I'm aware, but I thought
we could see a little more.
So I love games, he loves games.
I love winning, he might probably lose.
Might probably that's good.
So Sean has agreed to join
me in a friendly competition.
It's time to play Zoom Around The Room.
(soft music)
All right, it's simple.
Parents, you can even play
this at home with your kids.
I know that you're running
out of the circus thing
of trying to entertain your kids, me too.
So here's how it's done.
We'll be given a random word or phrase
by my executive producer, Alex.
Then we each run and find an
object to match that word.
And whoever gets back to their
camera first with the item
gets the point.
- Remember I just turned 50.
Remember I just turned 50.
- Well remember I might've
just moved out of this house
so I don't know what's here (laughs)
But I do have my running shoes on, so--
- Oh good!
- It looks like a cute dress,
but really I'm sporting
panting, I'm a working girl.
- Me too.
- Yeah, there you go.
All right well, don't slip,
those might be slippery.
Okay. Alex, go.
- [Alex] Wooden.
- [Kelly] Wooden!
- Oh wait.
(clock ticking)
- Well, I got it, right here.
oh (bleep)
(laughs loudly)
- I was sitting in it,
I was sitting in it.
- Oh you were sitting in a chair.
You win, you win.
I had a guitar, it was right behind.
I'm just happy I had
something wouldn't in here.
This is a guitar that I've never played.
Actually, this one isn't mine.
So yes, okay, I'm gonna
put this back up, hold on.
So it's still pretty
in the set, here we go.
Oh God!
- Look at your doggy, I love him.
- Oh, Henry is the best.
He literally is the
greatest dog, I lucked out.
Okay, what's the next word?
Sean gets that one.
Adorable.
- Adorable.
- I'm just gonna sit here.
Henry (whistles)
(laughs loudly)
Hi, hi Scott.
Hi Scott.
Okay I think my--
- I would have grabbed my
doggy, but he's sleeping.
- Hi, I like that I just...
What's up, man?
I literally just did this, you're welcome,
'cause I'm adorable.
I don't think I won that one either.
I don't know who's gonna get that point.
Okay, wait, do another word for us, Alex.
Disgusting, okay.
Disgusting.
(clock ticking)
- Is she ever coming back?
- I found something, plunger.
Oh, dog (laughs)
- I'm gonna put it back now.
- Ours both had to do with poo.
Okay, you get that point.
You had dog poop, that was awesome.
Okay, one more.
Okay, here we go.
- Okay.
Something that your mom
gave you, oh my gosh.
(clock ticking)
(indistinct)
- I'm funnier, if it's revealed.
- Okay wait, that took a minute.
'Cause this is hard for me.
Okay, what's yours?
(playing a slide whistle)
What is that?
- It's a slide whistle.
- I've never heard or seen that.
- You never heard the song,
"Groove Is In The Heart?"
- Yeah, (sings)
(playing a slide whistle)
Is that what it is?
- Yeah.
- Never knew.
Look at that, learn something
new every day, I did not...
Your mom gave you that?
- I don't know, I think so.
(laughing)
I don't have, I literally just moved...
I mean, obviously I took the things
my mother would have given me,
but she didn't give me a love of puzzles.
And I've been playing puzzles--
- Well, yours is sweeter.
- Okay, yeah, well, yours is cooler.
I didn't even know that existed, so--
- Wow, you need to put it in a song.
- I know I will now, I will steal that.
I will rip that from
"Groove Is In The Heart."
I think you kicked my butt, yeah.
- No.
- I had no chance in hell, that's awesome.
Hey, thank you so much.
- Yes, I adore you and it's
been so great to hang with you.
- Oh you too, and hey,
congratulations on Ricky.
He's horrible.
Goldendoodles are the best dogs.
You're gonna love him.
- I'm so excited, thanks honey.
- All right, well, it's
always great to see you, Sean.
I love you so much.
You can find Sean's new podcast,
Smartless, wherever you
listen to your podcasts.